what is going on with the whole trans
thing these days i don't know if this is
the direction by the way
if there's ever been a time you want to
be your friend you want to do that now
yeah
well no but here's the thing though you
make a very good point if there's ever
been a time to be a trans in palm
springs this is the time to do exactly
here's why here's why here's why because
palm springs woke council votes and
pilot scheme to pay 20 transgender
residents up to 900 a month for two
years in human universal basic income
but even cities mayor thinks it's a
waste of money uh palm spring is a is to
spend 200 000 on a guaranteed income
scheme not only applies to cities
transgender non-binary in california
city council voted unanimously on
thursday and favored the pilot scheme
which will give 20 residents between 600
to 900 a month for two years uh the city
council christie
uh backed the scheme told the letter
that she felt incredibly proud of the
city for coming in the right side of
history and supporting our trans and
non-binary gender non-conforming
community yes the mayor palm springs
lisa middleton who herself is trans and
transgender she's trans said
she did not think the scheme would
succeed but voted for it anyway so
um
how do you process that david palm
springs got 47 000 population
i think forty
six thousand nine hundred and eighty
people are going to become trans within
twenty
i've actually got the hormones in my car
if you guys would
this
this [ __ ] could really make you become a
total and cap likes check me out of
society the idea that they when they say
they're going to give money to trans i'm
going to give 900 that means they're
going to take money from someone else a
business owner in palm springs the guy
who owns the pizza shop will have a few
dollars or a few cents less than his
paycheck so they can pay trans people to
do what this has nothing to do with
being bigoted towards trans people i
want them to have the same equality and
dignity obviously i'm it's so boring
having to say all that stuff all the
time you know it's just like it's just
obvious
but what are they saying okay
okay so we're going to start paying
people with limps you know they got
problems too you know you got a limp you
see a guy walking down the street with a
limp you know pay this guy something i'm
gonna start limping dave you should
start limping you should start did they
say why they're paying them right that's
the but why
but but by the way one very interesting
thing can you pull up boris johnson what
he said yesterday oh god i think you can
say he's going trans did you hear what
boris said yes crazy hair oh by the way
did you hear what horses
you're going to be blowing away what
boris said yesterday okay
uh uh
put put biological he said biological
males that's the quote you want to pull
up
uh
okay there you go right there second
line make it a little bit closer so the
audience can see it he said this
yesterday
i don't think that biological males
should be competing in female sports and
maybe that's a controversial thing but
it just seems to be sensible so boris
johnson comes out saying
i don't think biological males should be
competing in female sports and maybe
that's a controversial thing but it just
seems sensible doesn't that sound like
common sense like my god a politician
telling the truth boris johnson out of
everybody from uk he seems to be nailing
it these days a lot of the quotes i hear
from him he was not in touch with his
wife but in in regards to the comments
he's making it's pretty simple so he
said i trust the british people to make
their own decisions that was the famous
lineup
i could have done it better i could have
done better if i get another chance for
that biz doc's actually great at accents
do you want to give it an english accent
no i'm not gonna
be shy i'm not gonna do that he's not
racist come on he's up
on the trans thing as a father of two
two girls i mean i felt terrible for all
those girls in the ivy league that were
competing with a guy that had longer
arms and size 13 and a half feet
those are called flippers by the way in
the water you know that's
however i look at title ix and i go wait
a minute wait a minute how many people
like gave their careers pushing for
title ix so we could have this
non-discrimination of budget and
decisions in women's collegiate sports
okay well then if you draw it out title
ix would actually com
support trans competing with trans
so
they're
why why is this such an issue and it
just it just shocks me because it's like
somebody wants it to be a wedge issue
nobody wants it to be solved there's
somebody that doesn't want it to be
solved they just want it to be a wedge
issue and that's
that's how i see trends by the way leah
thomas has a penis still by the way just
no just saying yes yes so it's still
william yeah
yeah now that does
that disappoint you well have you guys
have you guys seen the uh the time lapse
video that they showed on one of the
races when you see it you really realize
how out of control this is what the
penis
different
different video uh no you they show you
a time lapse of the race and when you
see him her whatever crushing them
you're like man it's just so obvious how
unfair this is but there's also another
incredible video that you guys gotta
gotta see uh from about six years ago
right before letterman stepped away from
the the late show he has serena williams
on and sick you saw this sick have you
seen this yeah no but don't you no no
you go ahead it's it's it's it's
incredible because oh what she says
about playing against men yeah she says
andy murray wants to play me yes he
would crush me she says she goes as far
to say this is her words yeah she says
men's tennis and women's tennis are
different sports yes i saw that
and this is the best female tennis
player of all time now you've got ron de
san just doing like a watered down
version of it and he's hitler that's
where we're at
what is
the lgbt and now it's q-i-e
i've seen you say a joke lmnop yeah
nobody knows what is it
nobody knows it doesn't matter and you
know on the trans thing look
uh douglas murray you guys may know
douglas murray he's a british
conservative writer really brilliant he
wrote a book called
madness of crowds and in it he happens
to be gay also and in it he separates
the chapter on lgb from t because these
things actually have nothing to do with
each other because one who you're
attracted to is very different i so for
example i have no more insight into what
it is like to be trans than you do right
bingo you're straight i'm gay okay
nobody cares actually except except for
the people constantly smashing us with
this
but the idea that these letters got put
together is very very dangerous and
actually i think in many ways it's it's
anti-gay because the gay movement the
people that were that were uh protesting
stonewall you know 40 years ago
and the entire gay movement was always
about equality harvey milk everything's
always about equality let us have equal
rights make sure that we don't have to
go to underground bars to meet people
and let us get married if i want to be
miserable and married like the rest of
you i have that right it's an old joke
but it always works thank you um
that's what it was about and the problem
is chris rock has a great line about
this in one of his stand-up specials
from 20 years ago the cops need a
certain amount of crime and that's
basically what the activists need so the
gay's got equality that's all he ever
wanted
you're equal do whatever the hell you
want you're an equal member of society
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]
you